I set the record for the lowest limbo of
8.5 inches in 2010 very proud of that
my name is Jamaica Campbell and I am a
world-class level dancer I'm originally
from Trinidad and Tobago which is also
where limbo dance originated it was a
dance at wakes to symbolize entering
from one life to another now today is
literally everywhere I got into the art
of limbo at the age of 14 my grandmother
was a limbo dance there my mother was a
loom look in there and it's only right
that I live with the answer I had to
carry on that legacy not only for my
family but also for my culture as well
physically I am very flexible I do my
daily stretches I can't really feel
normal stretches so I have to like
create my own so where I would really
feel the stretching my legs
I get a little crazy sometimes in order
to make it under 8.5 inches I have to
hold my breath in order to contort my
body to make it under the bar at the
same time I have to think about my arms
I have to think about my positioning I
move side to side just to show that I'm
still suspended I start to move actually
physically under the bar and that's
pretty much when I'm able to let the air
out and that's when I will get up it's
very very very hard to do the pain that
I feel
during practicing and pushing myself
that comes with it but that's one of the
things that really drew me to limbo it
was something that I couldn't do easily
I love the challenge me making it under
this bar perfectly every time
it means the absolute world I pretty
much limbo any and everywhere I've been
on America's Got Talent twice I've been
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show I've been on
The Late Late Show with James Corden
when I see people's reactions and how
appreciate that they are of my ability
to do this is just amazing I absolutely
love them both I love everything about
it
people think that limbo was just for fun
for Trinidadians like myself is really a
big part of our culture I feel like
that's where my job comes in to really
show you this is more than just a fun
little activity
you
[Applause]
[Music]